um michael i'm just going to go through
some questions here michael yeah i'm
going to send you um let me write this
down
it's interesting because i've sent out
when we released the new version of
overflows trader i've sent out everybody
the
the the links for that um
[Music]
like the whole entire week
uh
let's see how would you use a
conjunction with buying and selling
tails
blessing asks how would you use this in
conjunction with selling and buying
tails
well
you i don't know if i got tails turned
on on this well let's go back to the dao
okay so for example
um okay i'm not going to talk about
inverse imbalances now i'm going to talk
a bit about
tails i don't have tails loaded up on
here but you should be able to see where
they occur
okay so this is a selling tail
right up here at the high
right i i know it's a selling tail
because i see the two zero it's
highlighted there
if i start to see value migrating lower
right if i start to see a gap yeah i'd
get short right just as i get long if
there was a buying tail somewhere um
and value starts moving higher let's see
if there's one in here
you know here's a
got my cross crosshairs to white
uh
you know i loaded up an old chart that
was black color then i started changing
things to white i changed everything
except the crosshairs so this is a
buying tail right now i've seen the
value area gap up here okay
but again if you're seeing a buying tail
really you're just waiting for the next
bar to move higher right just says here
all right you're looking for the next
bar to move higher then sort of went
sideways fell down
but you're looking for that market to
just start to move away
oftentimes you're gonna get the buying
tail outside of the value area
right here's another one here mark a
little move up a little move up
move up no selling tail there
and this is on the open already
um can you simplify how you determine
the bid ask size information okay
dana um
well really all you're looking at when
you're looking at the bid ask
data
you're not necessarily looking at
every single
tick that goes through you know you
don't want to be
making more work than than is necessary
really what you're looking for is
volumes that are bigger than normal
you're going to be looking for
imbalances and when i say volume is
bigger than normal right all you got to
do is look at
it in relation to
earlier bars you know is it
more than normal or is it you know
lighter than normal okay so for example
see if there's any easy example here
there's nothing major happening normally
you're going to get the most of the
volume occurring inside the bar but if
you're sort of near the edges of a bar
and you're seeing you know heavier
volume than normal
pay attention to that
okay oftentimes
you know a clear sign is going to be the
value where the evaluator is generally
going to
be where the most volume is
and what day was this 31st
the way this market's been recently it's
been
you sort of get these bars within volume
then you get bars with heavy volume but
something like this here right
this bar
this red
excuse me this red candle okay so what
do i got in here right i've got this
imbalance appearing up here at the top
all right it's a red candle the market
turned down and normally on red candles
right somewhere up near the top you're
not on the top offer side as opposed to
the top inside
you're not going to see heavy volume
unless there's
someone with supply in the market right
and when you see an imbalance like this
a buying imbalance is what we call a
second
slot imbalance
which is a bearish signal that's what
this red thing has been drawn here
but normally 162 right you don't see
that type of volume in a lot of these
candles or the market's already moving
lower but here right you don't see much
volume up here you don't see much volume
here
um here's only 103 here's you know 115
really what you're looking for in the
top two or three price levels
right just as on the green candidate
you're looking
looking at the bottom two or three bid
levels so top two or three offer levels
bottom two or three bid levels you
basically you're looking at certain
spots in the bar for
um
you know
heavier than normal volume or the most
volume in the bar
okay so
that's you know in short i mean there's
more to it than that
but that's um one of the ways that i
would do it
um
edward asked what are the
red arrows and green arrows
so there's like different arrows they
mean different things like this
orange one would indicate market
weakness so i'd be looking for the
market to keep selling off and it's
read through the delta these red arrows
or like these green arrows
indicate um imbalance reversals
it's reading what's happening in the
imbalances in the bar for potential
reversal um
so there's sort of different signs of
you know we just highlight these things
because
you know the markets move fast and
oftentimes trying to
put everything together at once is
difficult so you know when i
my first
reason that i created the order of
illustrator software is specifically
to help me
take these trades that i might overlook
or by the time i realize it it's too
late right like for example if i see
this this market selling off you know
it's market yeah the market's already
weak but i could see based on the
aggressive selling
or sorry the aggressive buying that's
happening that the aggressive buying is
getting weak in here
then by the time i noticed it the market
made new lows already right but
having
an arrow drawn right it's not a red
light green light system right i still
gotta analyze what's happening in the
market it's going to tell me hey you
know what you got market weakness here
now i might not want to take it because
we're coming into the lows but
if the market is rallying and i get you
know a
sign of market weakness
then yeah i'd probably be looking to
take the short right again i'm not
always keen on selling into new lows
but
at least i know there's some weakness in
this market and maybe if i see some
other things in the order flow i may
want to get short or do nothing
um brian has multiple interesting traits
in his can you show what settings you
use on the one minute e-mini well ryan
the
the one minute chart right when you load
the indicator
all the the defaults for the indicator
um
is all set for a one minute chart a one
minute e mini chart and
in the past i would use
the same thing for crude oil but
obviously now with
everything happening in the world um
you know crude oil
has been a lot more volatile whereas you
know in the past i would use the same
settings
let's wait for this chart to come up
which setups are more important when in
trade what they look for ignore
well that's an interesting question need
basically what i'm looking for when i'm
in a trade
what i'm watching then is obviously
imbalances
right because you know say you're long
and you're starting to see selling
imbalances come in
that's not a great sign unless it's this
you know unless it's like absorption
happening
but you know if the market is
getting aggressive to the
short side
and you're long that's not a good sign
um
that that you want to stay in that trade
then obviously i'm going to be watching
what's happening in
the delta right if i'm long you know i
want to see the next bar have positive
delta and the next bar after that i have
positive delta if i start seeing shifts
in the delta you know once you're in a
position
of
you know either getting weaker or if
you're long you know delta's getting
weaker still positive but getting weaker
in the sense that you know it's not as
positive as earlier
you know that's a worrying sign and
obviously if it turns negative that's
not what you want to see
if um
you know if we'll be watching point of
controls how are point of controls
appearing
subsequent after getting into a trade
if
you know point of controls are migrating
higher and you're long that's a good
sign if you're starting to see lower
points of controls you know you know
prices
price and volume is going lower then
that leads into what's happening in the
value areas are the value areas
going lower or are they overlapping or
are they going higher right depending on
what position and if you're
in a long position and they start
overlapping okay
the markets probably
could be just be going sideways right
now
are the value area highs in the bars a
little bit higher
than they have been or are they
evaluated lows lower than they have been
or are the whole value areas
going in the opposite direction so you
know i don't say it's a holistic view
but you know
you're sort of it really becomes sort of
second nature you're sort of watching
what's happening um in it and i i do get
that oftentimes you know in fast markets
it's
difficult you know in the heat of the
moment you know you you want to be
um you know you want the trade to be
going in your direction but
you know for example here okay
all right so here's
you know a couple green arrows okay
imbalance reversals right you're getting
long okay so you say you're getting long
in off this first one
okay and you know you're along for about
25 we'll call it 25 make it simple
okay
it's a nice move up you know market's
still moving higher because remember
right you're getting long at 25 this
market opened up down here
okay so it had all this time put in this
value area the point of control of this
bar is higher than the previous bar
the bar ends up with a nice positive
delta of 78 all right and then the next
bar again point of control down towards
the bottom
close higher um we're still closing in
the value and then you get this red bar
here right now you got
um a tail here bearish tail
you've got a bearish eba
all right that's this red value area
obviously point of control is right
around the same level as the previous
bar
now you're still above your 25 entry
okay
you really just got to wait and see
right one thing you know i'm not a big
fan of immediately moving your stop
right up because what's going to happen
it's going to get a bar like this where
it trades right to your entry and then
takes off
now the next bar is a green candle okay
still inside but what are you starting
to notice nice positive delta of 28
previous bar had negative 18.
point of control is higher now value
area is still overlapping
it's still an inside
value area over the next bar
okay it's still
bullish i said you know one red candle
doesn't mean the end of
a trade
right a long trade it was because you
got one oh gosh i got one red candle i
could get out
even though it's got a couple
bearish things you know you still need
the order flow to confirm it right if
this next bar starts trading down right
if it starts trading down to
28 27 yeah then i might be a little
more concerned but it's a green candle
then this next bar opens up it opens up
higher immediately trades down to 25 but
you're left with a buying tail here
right then you got a bullish
uh point of control that's this green
point of control here
right the value area is still overlapped
and the bar closes closes green you
still got a positive delta of seven okay
so which is tiny
um
but yeah you still be in this position
okay then you start seeing okay you got
an next bar comes in point control
higher that's good
obviously the value area is higher nice
positive delta buying imbalances
okay then in here you're starting to see
you know more buying imbalances
point of control higher
then you start going inside right you
got this imbalance reversal here
you've got
the value area it's just it's so it's
overlapping by one or two ticks point of
control is lower okay negative delta
then x bar inside smaller bar
inside of the previous bar
evaluates inside point of control at the
same level
all right so now i'm starting to see
value is forming up here because
when i start to see value areas
becoming aligned like this
it's telling me the market is balancing
okay so now i know we're trading 56 the
market is potentially balancing in here
and then you know the red candle down
the negative delta the bearish eva the
lower point of control you know when you
get two point controls lined up like
this
i always watch the next bar where the
point of control appears if it's lower
that's not a good sign now you're
starting to see point of control from 60
down to 56
down to 52
you know you got the bearish eva now you
should start thinking about getting out
because even though you got that
positive delta of eighth it's kind of
small so you got selling up here right
after you made a swing high got more
selling up here
um you should be looking to get out
somewhere in this bar
rather than let the market come all the
way down to 25 and then come back up oh
that's where you get out now you should
be looking to get out in this bar
um roger asking he's a ninjatrader
yeah
well if you buy the software you don't
lose access to it so you can run the
software on the free version of
ninjatrader
yeah i got traders that trade in markets
that isn't supported by ninja trader
brokerage
they just use their broker front end to
execute the trades and they just use
free version and ninjatrader of course
you gotta get a data feed from like
kinetic or iq
feed
and then you just run my software on
there but you got to buy my software but
you don't lose access to it
um okay babe
so michael kemp babe i'll send you guys
the the the new version
um
what's the best time frame for nq
oh gosh um honestly the way the nq moves
now
i don't look at it that much i might i
do look at it mnq but i use mnq on a 30
second chart
and even that sometimes it's too
volatile honestly i don't really spend
much time on nq or mnq i just find
there's other markets that move
um
without all the
heartache
you'll move nicely and follow workflow a
bit better
than in queueing it's just a little bit
too volatile for me
um yeah jack it does work on wheat and
corn and beans um
obviously right you know nobody
until this whole ukraine situation blew
up
no pun intended
wheat is a great market for trading um
order flow wheat
and a lot of the grains are but
you know obviously we when it started to
run it up into those
limit updates and you can't do anything
but now it's sort of becoming coming
back to
a bit
normal
wheat but it's still kind of
thin um
so you can see here right you're still
getting a lot of
areas with very little volume if you
watch the order the depth of the market
on wheat you know you can see that the
bid offer is um
you know almost a penny wide
you know trades in quarters of a cent um
and then even in the order book there's
hardly much volume in there but on
something like wheat you know you can
use a
i use
50 and i use 100 range charts
but if you were to convert to 100 range
chart okay now you're getting some
decent
bars
you can start to see things a little bit
clearer like especially with the value
areas where they're gapping down like
this
all right because i don't i don't have
the
um
you know so you know on a 100 range
chart you're starting to see some i'm
sorry 100 tick chart 100 range start to
be useless
you're starting to see these gaps in the
value areas and you can ride these
trends a bit nicer right you're starting
to see sequencing coming in
you know on markets that are liquid
sometimes it's best to go to either a
range based chart or a tick based chart
just my opinion
okay in terms of
interest rates jordan s
ultra bond
bonds zn
the in my opinion the most um
useful
okay is well
if i was
if you're looking at um
we'll go to 10 years first right ultra
bonds ultra bonds is a great market i
mean there's a lot of things you can use
in there it follows order flow
terrifically but
you know if
if someone were to say mike you have to
trade one markets
and the market is 10 years
i'd use a range based chart
because you can't look you know 10 years
10 years is a very deep liquid markets
okay um and you can see the volumes that
trade in there you know this is a
four-range chart and you're seeing 1700
versus 165 you know you've seen volumes
in there four thousand six thousand five
thousand and you know even on slower
days you're seeing volumes of like
you know ten thousand eighteen thousand
but the market's moving you know um
quite nicely and
you know when you're looking at order
flow right you want a market that
the file is going to follow order for in
10 years you don't really have a lot of
the retail participation that you do in
in other markets
and
you know as a result
since its majority i'd say it's probably
about 90 percent 95 percent
institutional trade in there i mean
there are people that i know that trade
it on a retail level um
you know you're watching what's
happening in the volume okay and you're
looking for you know certain things in
here like i'd be looking at
um market weakness right these blue
arrows right imbalance reversals these
green arrows
and
for me i'd be looking at these
exhaustion prints right this this three
lot right coming you know this five lot
this is what's an exhaustion print is um
because you know you're talking about a
market
that trades
thousands at a level
all right this is the
exhaustion print here right so it's set
to nine
and it just comes down to a swing low
and trades three contracts normally at
each price level he's trading eleven
hundreds trading three thousand trading
thirteen hundreds trading 270 straight
1500 1900 399
2531 288 and she says three
pair trades five
i find that these offer great um
reversal levels
you know these are great spots for
reversals
and yeah
in
the difference with that and say
ultra bonds and
and regular bonds the zb
is it trades less volume right so for
example if you go to say
well let's pull up zb and zb here
um
the volume is lesser volumes you know
when
ultra bonds you know took off
more mainstream
volumes in the regular bonds you know
kind of shifted downwards in my opinion
now again this was friday which was
non-farm payroll day but if you go back
you know these other other sessions
you know here
well that's that's the evening session
if you go back like the day before um
you know i'd be looking for the same
things you know here's a six
right
six all right came down tested it again
this was a six here
six here one one
right you can adjust the level you know
four
it's um it just makes for some pretty
nice potential reversal signals
and ultra bonds is going to have less
volume
but that's what i would use
in um
those you know to me that that's
my favorite but problem is trading a
market like
zn 10 years is it's is very slow you got
to have the patience to
withstand it
um benjamin what create cheat sheets you
know that's a good idea create a cheat
sheet of all the indicators in version
five
um
yeah i could do that
because
again you know
at the end of the day though it comes
down to
finding parts of the order flow that
resonate with you that you know make
sense to you that you want to use it
like
i know that for you know liquid markets
looking at
market exhaustion to me it makes perfect
sense right because i know because i've
sat in front of the screen for
nights
you know for years
all night staring at the 10-year markets
right
and i know that when i see a little
volume trade at a level and the markets
start moving away that the move is often
going to keep going in that direction so
it's sometimes it comes down to finding
you know the one or two things that work
for you it's not about
everything is going to be working for
you at once but
finding something to focus on and then
building from there but that's a good
idea ben i'll try and
get it
um
bob i was away for a while did you cover
how to position the sequence tool away
from the bar
another off tools that get overlapped
with the sequence tool i need to
reposition
um bob i'm not sure what your question
is because send me a screenshot i think
that's the easiest
brian ask that was great watching your
thought process in the market open for
first two hours would make a great
teaching webinar
rather than scanning and
yeah brian you know it's always been my
plan to
sort of stream stuff i bought um i
bought everything for it except the
computer that i got
you know i bought these 4k monitors but
i think my graphic card on my computer
and the computer i got for that isn't um
supporting it properly so
give me some time um until i get a new
graphics card for that or upgrade that
pc but i do want to do some streaming
i think that'd be most useful um pepe
yes no i don't uh it's not on sierra
charts there's versions of footprints
out there for sierra charts but my tools
aren't available on sierra charts
anymore you may see my stuff with
another company
but i don't have any relationship with
them
theo is
soybean meal good contract to trade yes
it is um
a great contract to trade it's one that
i don't talk about much because it
doesn't you know it's not a
it's not a glamorous market um for a lot
of people
you know they're like a sewing meal the
heck is that but it it
it's something that
i i i'm active with it
and
it in my opinion it follows
order flow nicely
especially when you see big size coming
into the market at certain times now
there's certain things i like to look
for in soy meal but
you know
maybe i should create a separate uh
training on that but it is
it's a great market um
for trading you know one tick in soy
meal is ten dollars so
you know if you're getting these moves
that are
you know a dollar something you get you
know a dollar two dollars but think of
soy meals sometimes it goes into these
quiet periods as well where
trading is kind of you know for like
weeks and months where you're sort of
tight ranges but now you know with all
the volatility
in the markets in the sense of nobody
knowing what's going to be happening in
the ukraine in the supply chains and all
that
you're getting some nice movements
in soy meal
especially if you're positioned um
correctly but you know i like to look
for imbalances in there and
you know things like sequencing etc but
yeah soy meal is a great one
um
philip s can i use overflow for spot
forex
um
okay gord that's why
ninjatrader doesn't support 4k yet did
the same
um philip s can
you use the order flow for spot forex
you know if you're going to trade forex
your best just best
i don't trade forex but you know there's
currencies there's the euro currency
future on the cme
um that you can watch i know guys in
china
that use the software they trade forex
but you know they they watch the
cme contract
i mean even though you know obviously
forex
is a slightly different market um
you know the futures in in the actual
forex market are
obviously highly correlated but um
i know
i i have customers in in china that
don't trade the futures they trade forex
but they follow the
um
currency contracts on the cme they don't
trade the cme they trade the 4x though
uh
you use the same settings as es well for
soy mil and
and es i adjusted a little bit
because obviously for soy meal
you don't have as much volatility you
don't have as much volume
um
i'll show you got more vault in my
opinion it's a different type of
volatility i think than what you're
looking at in say the e-minis as opposed
to
soy meal right because it's got less
volume so
once it starts moving it can move pretty
quick
okay so like this is a one-minute chart
fridays
let's
um
you know activity so you know you're
seeing some bars obviously you're going
to get smaller volumes right seven then
the next bar is 157 right now 41. so
you're probably going to want to make
some changes one of the things that i've
been
doing with soy meal
go here
right is
i'm not going to use
exhaustion print of nine because
obviously the volume is lighter i use a
smaller exhaustion print um three
um i don't use
market sweep detector
um i don't use this i think i got zero
prints turned off
yeah zero prints turned off and
you know it
is this this is volume and balance you
know you might want to one of the things
i've been playing around with lately is
using a higher imbalance level um
instead of 300 or 400 i use
a higher one i'll let you you'll play
around with that and
um what other little things in here you
know primary point of control is i don't
use a third level i just use the first
two levels
but yeah there are some slight
differences
okay larry asked
um
can you show an example using mnq
okay sure
uh sorry nq or mnq there's nq
give it a moment to load up this is a
one minute chart so it's going to take a
while but let's see if i can switch it
to a 30 seconds
do i own or at least a seat no jordan um
i don't you know honestly now
commissions
are
i'll say low
but obviously if you have a seat it's
it's much lower
um
it's
i remember the days when
you know it was like 20 dollars you know
when i worked at edf man
years ago they had bought uh
index futures they had bought you know
jack carl futures
and
yeah there were brokers there i mean i
wasn't
a broker there but i was working on the
trading desk and you know the other
section i see these guys coming in at
seven in the morning
and you know they just you know they
have their customers and you know
they're charging their customers 20 25
around turn i mean now it's you know
basically what you're paying
through these retail brokers is is
is tiny
um
you know i remember when i was at dean
witter
and
you know we were allowed to have our
personal accounts and i was paying like
five dollars
this was back in the early 90s
um after i left the florida straight
upstairs you could have your own
personal account
and you're just paying and basically
i don't think look what the term was
x local or something like that
but yeah you're paying like five dollars
so um
and that's when the s ps are trading
like 300
and
it was like 25 dollars a tick so
you know if you're just sitting there on
the machine at night
trading your own account it was uh it
was a pretty good deal at that time but
here so this is um
enqueue okay so it's going back to the
inverse and balances right this is a
30-second but again you know the problem
is if you're on a one-minute chart
you know some of these bars are just
gigantic right you're talking it's a
30-second chart um
seven was that 749
and a half to 764.
you know that's what 15 points
so
you know it's that i don't want to go
down any shorter to a 15 second chart i
think that's too short but
you know i know the people that used to
trade nq on a
20 range chart and also now they're
trading a 40 range chart all right
because on the 20 range chart
when things started happening in the
last month they were just getting killed
they're getting chopped up very easily
so
it's it's harder but you know this is
the inverse imbalances that i was
talking about um earlier right this is n
and q
right and you know
the ebas and stuff like that
um you know there's another
bullish one here
it was a bearish one and it's just like
making the moves in one bar
you know so it's almost you know
it's always nice i guess to get into a
trade and out of a trade in a single bar
but um
you know this one you wouldn't have
taken because it didn't go any higher
this one you got here you got a nice run
up here
again then you get another one here
another bullish eva
market dipped down
and came back up this is where you you
drop your buy stop right up here at 35
14 8 35
and it makes the move but you know this
one bullish eva but didn't go any higher
here
okay again
because the bullish eva you know you're
long you're just dropping your buy stop
at 64.
so anyway guys um
you know that's
i forget if i
in honestly looking at a five minutes
uh
and q chart i think is
is
not practical in in order flow and the
reason i say it's not practical is
because
really with
the nasdaq
you'd have to turn your monitor from
landscape to portrait size to fit it in
there i mean i could try
but there's just too much going to be
too much information on there
so let's see it might even take a while
for this chart to come up but we'll give
it a try
all right philip thanks yeah um
ben that's a good idea starting point
let's see here cheat sheet starting i'm
just making some notes here
but um we'll see how long it takes if
this chart comes out because you know
the problem is right it's going through
the tick data and it's trying to load
and again you know i don't advocate open
up all new charts during trading you
know you
like for me right i have
my charts for
the market
and i don't deviate that much i don't
switch charts
um
during you know when the market's open i
just keep it the same and just keep it
running if anything i may open a new
chart right if you
use the tabs down here to open up a new
chart you know i just switch back and
forth
you know between the charts rather than
having to reopen a chart or change the
time frame on a chart i just find it
easier to
make it that way
um
well on my trading computer this is my
this is my like which i'll call this the
work pc or whatever
um this is the five minute chart i
got about
20 or 30 tabs open so it's about 20 or
30 charts it does take
a few minutes to load everything up
honestly but um well one and i keep that
one running pretty much all
all week i might shut it down midweek
and restart it you know during like
because on tuesday nights i do um a
weekly training session and because i
started like on my turn on my machine
i'll turn it on today sunday
i usually turn it around around three or
four
in the afternoon
for the five o'clock reopen then i'll
usually keep it open until
wednesday then sometimes i'll shut it
down
wednesday afternoon
during that uh recycle period and then
run it back up again
but
it doesn't lag or anything like that but
um
jordan uh do you keep yeah i keep
multiple charts open but again i've got
multiple screens as well um
you know people say well you don't need
multiple screens well yeah you don't
need it but it's nice to have
um you know i like to sometimes you know
some things are happening in one market
that i just might overlook
i don't really i don't
limit the number of bars per market but
you know days i i don't you know
sometimes people like to
load they'll load up a chart right and
they'll have this one days to load
they'll have it like set at 30 or
something
um
and i just keep the last day too you
know i think the default that i use is
three
which is fine
but you know this is a five minute chart
now the you can see it covers a lot of
space right obviously on
you know
some bars are going to be it's hard to
read if you're trying to look at a
footprint on on a five minute chart
you can adjust the font size of the
footprint to smaller
like for crypto
i think i got it set to eight
for bitcoin um
but if i on some of these other coins
like ethan and doge
they've got smaller ranges i i keep it
at um i think 12. i think this one is
set to 14.
but um
yeah um there's a question that i saw
about crypto or was it
i here find it but yeah they trade
crypto markets it's yeah you know you
can follow order flow
on crypto and really in my opinion it's
it's with crypto it's sort of like going
back in time to scene
because you're just basically looking at
the big volumes now obviously there's
some
limitations with crypto in the sense
that
you know for americans
um
you can't be on the big big exchange
finance right you got to be on binance
us but the data
binance
itself you know the the main exchange
trades
the most volume in the world um coinbase
is like second some of these other
exchanges are coming up i think ftx is
also rising in the ranks but coinbase
right now is is the second you get the
data for free from
ninjatrader they will connect to
um coinbase so
you know again if you're not familiar
with it you just go into
here right you just change your
connection to my coinbase you may have
to configure it up the first time but
again there's no username or password
you got to enter
um
but they got the historical date you
know the historical tick data but i i
use it i got one running 24 7
there the only time it goes down is if
windows decides to upgrade itself but um
yeah you're looking for the heavy volume
um i like to look at value areas that
are untouched as the market comes back
to it there are
things in
crypto order flow that i think are
significant but anyway guys i'm going to
end it there for today you know and
again you know if you're
interested in the software i see a lot
of these questions
some are coming from users some aren't
and um you know if you're interested in
the software we've got the special deal
just go to orderflows.com off 5 and
you're going to get a lot of stuff just
a one-time payment 7.49
so thanks for attending and
have a great weekend guys
um bob if you're still there send me a
picture of your chart um so i could
understand it your question a bit better
and
babe and michael i'll get you guys those
download links but
have a great weekend everybody and take
care
you